[Music]
ancient Egyptians spent much of their
lives preparing for death
now archaeologists in Egypt have an
earth mummification workshops in Sakara
where all the work was done to preserve
bodies for eternity it's the latest in a
string of discoveries hope to draw
tourists back to Egypt
this Workshop is the one used for humans
including the bets on which the bodies
were washed we found a small hole
through which the water flows after
washing the bodies we found the tools
used by ancient Egyptians to cut their
bodies to remove internal organs as well
as the canopic jars used in
mummification to preserve internal
organs
two tombs have also been found in burial
grounds near the famous step pyramid of
Dozer
this burial chamber is more than four
thousand years old and belonged to a top
official
inside the tomb we found all the daily
life scenes like Harvest like
cultivating like like a musical band
musical instruments a guy who's playing
the slot and stuff like that anyhow it's
very very important this guy
he used to work like a high priest for
the goddess might and also Priests of
breezed off a god Horus and he was the
supervisor of digging canals for
irrigation
and also he got the title of the chief
of the writers
the tombs of wealthy Egyptians were
filled with treasures to accompany them
to the afterlife grave robbers looted
much of these valuables but this statue
is among items found intact in another
team that's over 3000 years old
death rituals in the ancient Egyptian
civilization were shrouded in mystery
these discoveries could shed more light
on the burial rights Barbara angupa Al
Jazeera